hey guys welcome back to the Evan and
Kaitlyn podcast the podcast that is a
hundred percent advertiser family and
should always be monetized good one
appropriate for the for the context of
the show so one of the themes running
through this podcast is going to be some
recent I feel like I feel bad cuz like
we've been hitting a lot of new YouTube
news lately but there's and it is our
life and and if again if you guys are
watching this you guys probably watched
YouTube too and I think this is gonna
continue to affect content creators in
this field basically three youtubers
created a video where they looked at a
whole bunch of of words and how
YouTube's robots behind the scenes like
interpret those words and what is
demonetized and all of that yeah so
we're gonna be talking about that some
and also we're we're Kailyn will ask me
a few words and I'll try to guess which
one is will D monetize your video
instantly and which are safe and
approved but first we have a few what's
new updates
yes one of the biggest thing that's
affecting us and other content creators
that you might be watching is the
removal of the real-time subscriber
count which we talked about recently and
we talked about it in sort of like ah
man this is kind of annoying because we
like seeing those daily numbers like by
the apples cuz we're addicted to it
because like it's like a drug that we're
just like continuing to consume and we
get that dopamine I know I'm getting
into it a little bit it's like one of
the reasons are one of the things about
it is it's like a gamble every time yeah
cuz you're not only looking at your own
by the hour numbers you look at other
people's by the hour numbers and so
you're like well how hard like my peers
doing over here and how are my peers
doing over there and so it's a gamble
sometimes you look and you're doing it
better than them and you're like you
know what um I'm doing pretty darn good
you're good you look at someone else and
you're doing what
worse than them and you're like my
channel sucks it's terrible and so it's
like sometimes it's a dopamine hit
sometimes it's not yeah and I think in
general I think that there's a large
group of people that are very vocal that
they dislike it yeah and that way that
they dislike just like the change they
want the real-time subscriber count to
be brought back and there's like I mean
we talked we kind of felt shared the
same sentiment but like still if you go
on Twitter if you go on to YouTube's
like main account really I mean like if
you want to get how people are feeling
about YouTube just go to any YouTube
post and it's gonna be filled up to put
people with comfor like everyone is
complaining about YouTube but people are
still wanting it back but I think our
conclusion how it is personally affected
the two of us which doesn't mean that's
how affected how it's affected other
people but for the two of us we check so
much less I haven't looked into it in
like days yeah I haven't checked herself
counting days and it's it's not just cuz
we can't like we can still on the back
end see our exact sub-county number it
just doesn't tell you by the hour how
many you gain to that hour you know you
would have to like do some math in your
head or track it yourself but but we
don't even like check the number as much
anymore like we still could get a daily
total from YouTube that's easy and we
still want to do well we still want to
win at this game that we're playing I
mean it's not really a game and there's
no winning because it goes on forever
and there's no like there's no but like
you know we still want to like do well
and do the best that we can but I think
that's the thing like if we are just
doing the best that we can at all times
then we can just say we're winning them
as much as we can you know and I think
that's kind of a healthy approach to
take you know it's like I have become so
much less obsessed I I don't even know
how we have done in the past period of
time and I kind of want to keep it that
way I kind of almost don't want to look
I know part of me cuz we haven't looked
in several days I know especially
because we took a buffer week oh and
that's painful like the last week was a
buffer week and we always get fewer subs
on a buffer we just make sense we're not
putting out a video and buffer weeks are
good for our mental health but when
women
for him we're obsessing over how many
less subs we and if during the the
buffer week we're looking still looking
at our sub count every single day and
it's painful
like how much better is it for our
mental health to take a little bit of
like get ahead period of time that's a
de monetizable word what I know what
sorry we'll get more to that later so
can be in the title I mean say it but
also it's like I think that there's some
thoughts on this list whereas if these
words are very heavily featured in the
very beginning of your video it can be
monetize the video to oh like in your
closed captions yeah well sometimes
people change their closed captions to
not say what they're saying yeah I've
noticed especially people like curse
word
tricky tricky yeah I've done it for
something - I don't remember what it was
I think I turned because we would say
like oh my god and I turn it - oh my
gosh just in case just in case who knows
and you know the podcast who cares it'll
be what it'll be and there's enough
words in here to clutter everything up
but I think that like in general the the
change has been a good one and that
makes me kind of rethink would it be
good to hide the likes on Instagram and
Facebook and Twitter is that still
something that is being - yes next you
haven't been mixed okay so just to
update if we haven't talked about it
before if you guys didn't know Instagram
is it facebook also Facebook also yeah
they're testing it in Australia right
now they're testing removing likes from
photos so like you can see it on the
back end but it's not public so you're
not comparing yourself to others yeah
it's very interesting interesting yeah
cuz because I still do that I'm so damn
like when I when I look at ours and I
will like look at another content
creators and I'll compare yeah I'm not
above that all of them there's not like
it there's not like a great it's not
like Instagram saying you get an a your
channel and your profile are doing well
yeah good job
other way to know if you're doing it
right comparing yourself and at the same
time I mean like comparing us to someone
else is like comparing an apple to a
pineapple you know like a football
that's a better analogy because they're
completely different yeah and like
someone could be the same size as you on
Instagram but their full-time thing is
Instagram and they're gonna get way more
engagement you know or whatever the
thing and different people use different
platforms for different things it's a
while bless no one knows what they're
doing I mean some people know what
they're doing but like there's no
there's no rules there's no rules that
are in place yeah FTC rules but I think
that like that my experience with
YouTube hiding the sub-account makes me
more receptive to the other platforms
you would think wouldn't that make us
like not compare ourselves to other
Creators on like Instagram for example
or do you think it's just cuz like we're
a scrolling on Instagram you can't help
but see the amount of likes it has III
can't help and because it's there
because it's public I'll do it yeah all
like oh I wonder how we're doing
compared to this person yeah I do you do
that too but if that option was taken
away from us would be like oh we can
compare ourselves ourselves like I don't
do that on Twitter I know you do
sometimes on Twitter I don't do that all
Twitter is like our smallest platform
and I enjoy Twitter I enjoy Twitter so
much and so like I have no idea how many
followers we have on Twitter I can tell
you what we have on YouTube and
Instagram but I can't tell you on
Twitter but like also of like we're
still like I'm still trying to find like
our feet I'm still trying to find our
voice on Twitter
do we like post personal things as we
post updates on the project is there a
mix to be post funny memes to be post
like funny things we find you know where
I'm still finding that voice and
sometimes we get like more likes and
we're now we're going through a period
of less likes on Twitter and I'm like
what am I doing wrong
I don't know whereas I'm like Twitter's
fun yeah and I mean I generally on
social media I'm kind of like about
likes and stuff yeah me too
you know it's not a
it's there's not too much reason to
stress a lot because we don't do like I
don't want to Iseman sir ads on Twitter
occasionally we do it on Instagram but
only when a sponsor that we're already
working with on a video like hey can you
guys throw in an Instagram post and it
feels like kind of natural you know it's
like it's part of our content or making
anyways yeah that's not my point
my point is like we shouldn't worry
about them because they don't like the
numbers just like a vanity number yeah
but it's also like a number of how good
you're doing at all of it it's like yes
it is a little bit of a vanity number
but it also is like a grade it's like
the public is grading you and you know
we both like good grades I think that's
part of it like is I'm trying to be
honest with myself am i vain I don't
know but I don't really think so in
terms of that like before we were doing
social media for business
I can't tell you like how many likes my
pictures go oh eight I don't know no I
think that we are looking at them as a
grade yeah and I think that that's why
we get kind of sucked into like the like
beast I mean I think that we are like
chatting with Simone at Maker Faire Bay
Area and she was like don't let that
don't let the Beast eat you or something
like that because I think everyone
understands like like all content
creators understand like even without
context they would understand what that
sentence means and and the temptation to
give in to like the beast and letting it
take over your life and like trying to
feed feed it or something the Beast what
were we talking about oh yeah this is
all about the truncated sub count going
away and our thoughts on it
speaking of feeding the beast yes we
recently tried to feed ourselves a
Popeye's chicken sandwich after
everything online okay so I'm not sure
if you guys are aware of this thing
that's going around it on the internet
because we are consumers of internet
culture now but I really like also out
of date consumer culture yeah there's
like there's a whole thing where Popeyes
announced a chicken sandwich and started
like kind of fake Twitter beef with
chick-fil-a yes
back and forth and this and that and
everyone's been like comparing yeah
comparing them and posting about it
making videos about it and like I I was
just like cuz I'm like we like
chick-fil-a food and it's not that we
don't like
Popeyes food I just haven't been to a
Popeyes and really long time so I was
like I mean I'm sure it's fine but I
didn't really think too much about it
and then we were listening to the h3
podcast and they ate them on the podcast
and like reacted live and I was like I
have to draw the [ __ ] I'm so susceptible
to food marketing even though they
weren't trying to mark it it's just it's
like watching or it's like driving on
the highway and you see a billboard for
McDonald's fries and you're like I need
fries now that's my brain and I was like
I gotta try this Popeyes cheese now much
but it's so interesting from a marketing
perspective what Popeyes did they
started they started a fight with their
competitor who like and like it's such a
good marketing campaign it's pretty much
free and everyone loves like this versus
and weighing in everyone wants to do it
and then like it's a free viral
marketing campaign it's like so genius
here we are perpetuating we're marketing
for them right now we're part of the
system Kayla sponsored by Popeyes part
of the system I know but yeah so we were
like after after listening to that
podcast we're a little behind on the
podcasts but after listening I was like
we should go try it we should just go
try it so we're we're actually on our
way to dinner going somewhere else when
I brought it up and we were like let's
turn the car out so we turn the car we
literally like we're all like on the
on-ramp to a freeway and did you turn
and we didn't even like know where
Popeyes was near us so we're like look
at it up okay we're doing it and so
we're so excited and we're like we'd
heard that they had run out in some
locations and we're like but Houston's a
big city yeah yeah Houston so big like
like I'm sure they have them here and so
we get there were like yeah and as soon
as we get in there's all these giant
signs saying that there's none and we
were very sad I'll be back November
first so it's in our calendar
we'll let you guys know but you guys
know there will be an update stay tuned
for the reveal because we are we are
chicken connoisseurs evidently now
apparently and our opinion matters well
I'm another interesting news thing that
I have kind of been like it has been
consuming my life easily but um we uh
you know as you guys know we started a
gaming well we started a twitch channel
and we streamed there then we were like
oh we should put highlights on YouTube
and so we did that but that was the
gaming channel that's our gaming channel
but then we got some requests for the
full stream uncut versions to be
uploaded to youtube so we started doing
that evident Caitlyn gaming gaming as
unlisted videos and kind of hiding them
and making them publicly available but I
kind of hid him because it like it got
and made the video feed really messy and
we don't want people getting all these
notifications of uncut you know two to
three hour long videos if what they
signed up for was like 15-minute
highlights long story short we launched
our fifth channel and I think that we
announced that we were gonna do that on
the last podcast but we have done it all
of the videos are up there it has been
unand ever
it's like uploading all of them and
doing all the thumbnails and the
captions and the playlists and linking
it like just when you're dealing with
two to three hour pieces of content like
we we would re export them because
there's at the beginning of stream
there's like a bit where it just says
stream starting soon for like a couple
minutes and we didn't want that in every
video so we have to react sport them
which takes a long time we'd to upload
them which again we talked about this on
the live podcast but we like maxed out
our internet it's done it's done and I
think it's really exciting because it'll
allow us to you know get plays out
earlier like if there's a game that just
launched we can like play it and upload
it and like beat the system and get it
out there soon and and you know it's a
better viewer experience and twitch is
really hard
navigate for like past streams well plus
like there's there's some websites that
I go to that embed twitch stream is like
twitch highlights and sometimes the like
like the bandwidth from twitch on those
is like horrible I'm like trying trying
to play a video and I take so long to
load and it's buffering and I scroll
down and I'm like isn't my internet
speed
I click the video and it's like Bing
Bing bong let's play right away and
which bus every now and then the
experiencing like bandwidth issues which
is why I like YouTube is just killing it
on the video space because I mean this
is an interesting thing
I started Evan and Caitlin gaming uncut
and it's a brand new channel and Here I
am uploading hundreds of gigabytes worth
of data some YouTube is just taking it
they're not asking anything from me as a
brand new channel and they're just
hosting it all which is like really
expensive and really hard for anyone to
compete with YouTube just like does that
yeah that's insane anyone can just
upload hours and hours and hours of
footage even if you has no confidence
that anything good is gonna happen
yep one thing that was interesting
though is they were slower to load the
videos worked the videos totally worked
but I think it's just because the
channel has lower priority I think that
those videos are in cold storage whereas
videos that are being accessed all the
time they get duplicates made live
because like think about it like Shane
just like the night we're recording this
Shane has launched his second Shane
Dawson has launched his second video and
I bet that's gonna get 30 million views
within a couple days now if YouTube only
has one copy of that video on their
servers it's gonna fail and YouTube
doesn't want to fail because he didn't
want to play those ads and I bet for
channel like Shane's that channel has an
estimated view per video so YouTube is
gonna pre duplicate that video and it's
gonna have like a hundred or a thousand
copies out of that video on hundreds of
servers all across the world in advance
so when he launches it the system knows
to do that
as expected you can yeah but our our
video that we uploaded that has no views
from a brand new channel they're only
gonna have one copy of that on a slower
server in Antarctica not not really not
really but like you know I put the way
these servers work you know I think they
can't see on they can't duplicate those
videos pretty quick but it's not
necessary Gnaeus they have some pre
predict how many views the videos gonna
get and that's how that's that's a tough
saying from an infrastructure standpoint
yeah which is why YouTube is killing it
and no one can compete I like YouTube I
love that they provide us with a service
but I think that like competition in the
marketplace leads to innovation and and
really YouTube has like has no
competition you guys I mean there's been
speculations that like maybe Facebook
can Amazon started this guys I don't
know if you know but Amazon started a
short clip thing you can apply you can
get you can put your I we could start a
like series on Amazon just because
Amazon is Amazon and it's like
everything and it did get to the videos
you need to go to like a subsection of
Amazon and like filter it and finding
it's impossible doesn't make sense for
them financially to make it its own
separate thing that has all these
marketing dollars behind it unless
enough people are on it and the only way
they're gonna get enough people on it is
to pull alike who is it that stole ninja
mixer mixer they're gonna have to pull a
mixer they're gonna have to like pay a
bunch of the top creators over there
they're gonna need a lot that's a lot of
money yeah that is a lot of money cuz
like whole careers are on YouTube like
the bigger you get on YouTube the more
you're like crosslinked the more you're
like tied in like leaving YouTube when
even on there for eight years would be
way more painful I think than twitch and
to mixer because those are live you know
it's like everything going forward
that's the only thing that matters your
past catalog doesn't matter that much
yeah but YouTube you for life
huge huge and like if you stop creating
content
for that channel then your past catalog
is gonna like war in crash potentially I
don't know it could yeah it's crazy
that's crazy what were we talking about
not that you go on content on tangents
that much YouTube oh yeah the gaming
uncut oh yeah and then the how they
hosted all this content with very like
with no reason to get have faith in us
to have faith in that new channel um but
I do kind of wish that on YouTube you
could create one channel that has like
monetization enabled and you can create
sub channels from that channel yeah that
are instantly monetized because it's the
same creator and everything although
that might get to be used
I could see it getting abused I don't
know I mean that's what playlist or for
yeah I think it was like the reason we
couldn't just have like ebony Caitlyn
gaming with it evident Caitlyn uncut
playlist is like we would want to have
playlist within the playlist
yeah you know what I mean like we want
to have a Minecraft uncut and a
unravelled uncut yeah all these
different things and it gets just starts
getting messy but also like if you the
listener likes our uncut then you might
subscribe for that content but if you
only like the edited stuff you won't
want notifications for each and we want
to send out notifications for both types
of content because when we stream in the
very next day we're gonna publish the
uncut version of that stream for anyone
who wants it right away
and we want that notification to go out
but we don't be sending out all these
notifications because then people are
gonna turn off notifications so it's
just like a struggle that I've seen so
many channels struggle with I mean
Philip DeFranco started his podcast on
one of his like 3 or 4 channels and he
was like oh this needs to be its own
channel and he made its own channel but
the first few episodes are on a
different channel not a conversation
with podcast channel so I think it's a
struggle that so many people straw it's
a it's a difficulty that lots of
youtubers struggle with and I think it
also restricts the type of content that
people can make
because if we could launch different
types of content with different
expectations I think we might you know
it would be easier for us to start a van
in Caitlyn cooking channel not that we
are going to start a cooking channel but
like or if we wanted to do like Evan
reviews technology and Caitlyn
doubtfully evaluates the cost of them
you know if we wanted to like do
experiments like that in the future like
we wouldn't want to put them on one of
our channels where that doesn't fit but
starting a new channel is so painful
yeah and it's like if you're not gonna
commit to that concept of tech reviews
or cooking or whatever then it's it's
like why go through the trouble of
starting the channel if you're not gonna
be doing them you know at least a couple
times a month time so we don't obviously
know what the answer is but I wish there
was a little bit more flexibility there
even if it was like you could subscribe
to a playlist I think that would be
interesting it's like when you click
Subscribe maybe by default you were
subscribed to the whole Channel
yeah but then if there were like when
you got notifications though there are
certain types of videos that you didn't
want to be subscribed to you could
unsubscribe to that playlist now that
would require the content creator to
have playlists have them be organized in
a way that makes sense to people yeah
that would be interesting or like if you
don't want to subscribe to the channel
you could just go down to the playlist
and subscribe to those playlists yeah
like maybe I want to watch Brad videos
and clear videos but I don't want the
actual like cooking tutorial yes great I
want to subscribe to yep it's live with
Brad and they're like gourmet gourmet
yeah I'd love to just some track of them
all of them maybe there's a couple more
I want to yeah maybe I want back-to-back
chef yeah you know whatever it is but
that would be an interesting way to do
it also yeah cuz like when when your DVR
and shows you can choose like watch
their record all of Mythbusters or
whatever you don't need to subscribe to
like all science to all Discovery
Channel you know yeah yeah that's
interesting that's interesting okay
so main topic time the nerd city video
so nerd City if you guys haven't ever
encountered the channel it's it's a
really interesting channel unlike Kaelyn
and I
like say he's kind of like the the
youtubers youtuber he kind of does
things so well when I watched his videos
I just get so pumped on like oh man like
his style is so unique his story is yeah
his storytelling the way he presents
information is just really compelling
and intriguing like even if this stuff
doesn't affect you at all like this kind
of behind-the-scenes YouTube stuff it's
just so interesting to watch yeah the
videos like that sounds so cool he
deserves so many more selfies he
deserves so many more subs than he has
but one of the first time he came to our
attention I would believe it was for the
hidden codes hidden code so so back
probably like a year ago if you right
clicked on a YouTube video web page and
you said you clicked on see browser
source in the code of that YouTube video
it had like codes in it and the codes
were tagged something like exclude ads
or something like that or like I don't
remember the exact wording basically
there's a section on that source code
where there were certain numerical codes
that were like flags for certain types
of content different things that could
get UD monetized and this happened
this video came out after our propane
cannon which is our first demonetized
video and we had like the next 10 or so
videos getting monetized after that and
so we were like what's going on and then
we saw that there were overlapping tags
and go to monetize videos what does this
code mean YouTube tell us what sounds
like we would avoid it if you told us
yeah but so so he does a lot of videos
like that but the latest one is I mean
he hits a few different topics yeah I
think the one that we're gonna at least
what the game is based on is like this
demonetized words list and what was that
a seal oh is that the name of the other
well link all of the name is down down
in the description below but basically
when you're trying to figure out how an
algorithm works if you could just see
what the rules of the algorithm are you
can kind of understand what it's looking
for and what is prioritized in
YouTube obviously can't show anyone what
their black boxes is deciding on but
basically another way to understand a
black box is to look at the in and out
and if you give it enough end and enough
out then you can kind of look for
patterns you know what I mean and the
patterns that came out were some were
very obvious you know profane words and
stuff like that some look bad for
YouTube and some were just completely
confusing yeah yes there's this huge
list of war words was it like ten
thousand it was definitely in the
thousands of words and some are marked
green as in there good and some are
marked yellow as in you will get
demonetised and then some have a little
asterisks by them saying you can get
demonetized like with when certain other
conditions are met and this word is used
and basically they like make it like
even out the playing field on the video
basically they just uploaded two seconds
of content of like almost nothing and it
is all they did is change the title so
it's like if they uploaded we had I
don't know how to think of like a word
that's that's fine but a word that's
fine that shouldn't get flagged but it
did get flag okay oh yeah mental health
yeah if you uploaded a video saying I'm
gonna take a mental health break from my
channel yeah I'll be back in a month
then theoretically like that would get
do you monetize but if you changed it to
I'm gonna take a happy break from my
channel instead of a mental health break
from my channel then that wouldn't get
to monetize or if you you publish a
video called I'm gay that would get to
monetize but if you said I'm happy
then it won't yeah and that just like oh
that guy goes against a lot of things
that YouTube is saying is saying that
they stand for it and you know like
YouTube isn't necessarily and what they
said is look we don't have a list of
words that are bad and that will do
monetize the video which technically is
correct because they don't have a list
but what they do have as an algorithm
that consistently flag certain words as
the monetize or monetize hot
by like actions that happen and so one
of arguments of the video is that even
if there's not like a strict policy in
place saying like well this word has to
be flagged what's happening is when
things are being sent for manual review
they're being sent to places all over
the world and there's different
viewpoints all over the world about
what's appropriate and what's not so if
there's enough people that mark certain
terms inappropriate then the algorithm
thinks like well this is an appropriate
yeah you know and one thing that Philip
DeFranco touches on in his in his videos
I mean he touches on a lot of news a lot
of controversy a lot of things that are
you know blowing up in the moment and
oftentimes those are very controversial
so Philip defranco's videos often Kitty
monotypes he says the majority of his
videos get be monetized just because he
touches on all these controversial
things and a lot of words in the list
are words that got flagged for recent
controversies and events because pretty
sure the word controversy is flagged oh
my god the word allegation was flagged
what so lots of news words lots of news
type words also was super surprising as
loss of location words yeah like like
New Zealand and North Dakota and all
sorts of this is gonna be like my
example for the game North Carolina and
South Carolina flagged back Wow
North Dakota South Dakota okay good
so like YouTube like the Dakotas well
there must be some news things that go
on there we're like bad stuff is
happening and YouTube like I will say
reading the word list cuz I prepped for
the game later thinking like quiz Evan
there's a lot of terms that I have never
heard before a lot of like bad words bad
words Oh bad words sad words or just
like combinations like a bad word plus a
not bad word and I'm like that's a funny
insult oh my gosh that's interesting oh
oh we can't we can't share give them
my game was just like PG version that's
really interesting yeah I mean I think
that one one thing that I liked about
the nerd city videos he didn't just say
like here's a problem that we found wow
this is bad I'm sad you know he kind of
like threw out a few suggestions on how
to kind of like change the narrative
around monetized and and all of this and
I think that one thing that's really
interesting is look the the AB that
plays before these videos is targeted to
you the person that's listening or
watching like the ads aren't a
reflection of the content you're about
to watch they are a reflection of the
watcher because that's who they're
targeting they're not really how it
works they're not targeting the content
they're targeting the watcher and I
think that if word can spread and if
understanding can spread that this ad
that played before this controversial
content they're not connect it's not
linked to the contents not linked to the
content you know and it's like hey
company your ad was playing next to this
bad video and like why are you watching
that bad video you know this is you are
watching the video and the car the ad
was targeting you so it's like this
means you're saying that you're a bad
person
I ate it with you yeah or whatever
whatever the situation is but I think
that like that's a really really good
point yeah I don't know why there isn't
more awareness being spread of that
especially by YouTube education to the
advertisers yeah make youtube's life a
lot easier cuz cuz in the way it's like
you know if a I think that with
traditional media if an ad played before
a show they were able to watch that show
they kind of like are associating
themselves with the show yeah it was
prevented it was we've had it and like
if you know coca-cola is able to play
right before what's that what's that
hands maids tale hey fellas like I'm not
sure I think Henry tells on like Hulu or
something so there's no
like I used to show that we've not
watched but like there's I heard that
the bad thing is in the hands maids tale
which like the handmaid Co shame show
there were hands make things handmade
show oh you know I hear that there's bad
and like like there's there's very
controversial like shows like that car
like you know advertisers like yeah
let's put our ads in front of that but
if like if that same content was on
youtube or on YouTube that would not be
monetized right like that's that's very
interesting to me because because
because sponsors have more to do with TV
and choosing to do that than they do
with YouTube so I feel like there should
be more burden on sponsor you know like
ads before TV then there is for YouTube
bitten - just like immediate and so big
yeah but obviously like the advertiser
doesn't have control like fully they
have like they can shoot some metrics
but I mean oh maybe they can pick like
put me here but they probably pay more
but like I don't know yeah I don't know
- no or we're speculative man but yeah I
did think it was cool that he offered
some like advice and stuff or like
wasting before it yeah okay then you
know what time it is it's game time it's
game time
[Music]
Cayla not prepared everything so I'm
just gonna close my eyes I'm not gonna
look at the list because she has
prepared some things and I think that
you guys are already like in the know on
what the game is so we won't explain it
again did we explain it it's called
demonetised or not and I'm just gonna
say words I tried to group them in
interesting ways okay sometimes I might
give you one word and you guys have its
demonetized right sometimes I might give
you a list of words and you say which
one is demonetized
Oh sometimes there's - you gotta guess
what's what I like this I like this
games then games game master Caitlyn and
you guys can play along what a fun game
okay I use my North Carolina South
Carolina that's good not together okay
here's two words I'm not gonna tell you
if they're both the same thing or if
they're different one is shocking the
other is emotional and I chose those two
because those are often used in title no
way a most shocking emotional okay
emotional is monetized shocking is
demonetised
no you're right yeah cuz cuz no one does
so many people do emotional emotional
was the trigger so many people wouldn't
be doing that emotional yeah but I think
that makes sense
shocking cuz who are you shocking in a
title like in in a real way no I mean if
you're like shocking scientific
discoveries yeah yeah yeah yeah like I I
went to go see how Pringles were made
and it was shocking that video took the
title this the shocking podcast no cuz
then we're gonna get you monetized okay
this is kind of in the same vein
satisfying uh monetized nope what I
think the satisfying slime slime slime
satisfying ASMR but I'm sure that
there's like that this is one that made
me think like it can't just always be
installed oh it no this is
a caveat that and we don't have the
exact numbers here but like the people
who gave this a score of like zero to
one and zero always means like always
monetize this is a fully safe word one
means this is always demonetised and but
like you know if it's green if it's zero
but if it's anywhere on the scale of
like potentially de monetizable it's
yellow yeah you know so some of these
like like it might the the bot might
need some more contacts that's like I
think some instances were like if every
single word is a demonetised word you
but if it's just like one and the other
words are green shocking satisfying
experiments two strikes she strikes yeah
yeah but what about our um video we just
put out the million layer clay video
that was a shocking satisfying
experiment yeah what if we titled with
that Wow we'd be do you monetize that'd
be sad okay hmm um here's a few that I'm
gonna give to you in a group dr. Dre Dr
Pepper dr. Phil what dr. pepper safe dr.
Dre do you monetize dr. Phil safe
they're all safe okay you are so clever
it's like thank you it's like we were
playing this game out of a called what
the golf and they kept on like changing
the rules and you just never know what
was gonna happen
you ain't the golfing you you are what
the golf of me okay um okay coffin
do you monetize its do you monetize
anything what if what if there's like a
woodworker who wanted to make a coffin
or I thought of simply's video we should
make the shooing the hollow coffin and
simply instead that our videos have
gotten to be monetized before it's
multiple videos maybe because she says
peel porn simply no logical christine
peels her nails off she does a peel off
base coat so that she could peel off her
nail polish her nail polish okay every
every like pretty much everything I saw
that was death related like dead dying
eulogy funeral Wow yeah but coffin was
interesting just because it made me
think of the assembly analogical video
Wow um okay well you're gonna have to do
the titles from now on because like you
have the knowledge of the demonetised
words acne zit skin cancer cancer acne
demonetized
zit demonetized skin cancer safe cancer
safe acne demonetized
zit safe which is weird what cuz like it
I don't understand
skin cancer monetized cancer is context
sensitive some cancers and more
monetized and some Rd monetized it was
like half half in the list I love that
that's crazy yeah so like and same with
a lot of like medical terms medical
terms were like all over the place brain
tumors good breast cancer bad arthritis
bad indigestion good explosive diarrhea
bad shocking shocking ly satisfying
explosive diarrhea
demonetised forever your whole channel
gets a strike dozens dozen what what
okay dozen safe dozens demonetised so
wait what you said it so fast dozen
dozen is okay dozens
demonetized you're right what made you
think that cuz because that's cuz it's
click bTW
okay I always think what's the click
baby thing cuz like dozens like who like
that could be a lot but like most people
who are being like serious would like
say the number or be more specific or or
some like dozens seems like like a like
an exaggerated e term interesting you
know and I think that like one thing the
reason why I think I've been able to
choose some of these and you know I
could just be like saying oh I
understand this to some small degree and
then all the rest I get wrong but I
think the reason why I have some
confidence and this is the way the bot
is trained and I think that we we
experienced some small part of this wave
but basically when the ad pocalypse hit
YouTube just started D monetizing
everything anything that it thought
might be dangerous
got be monetized and then they hired
tens of thousands of humans to review
all these d monetized videos dozens of
thousands of people to review this and
these people would watch the video and
they would say is this a good video or
is this a bad video and that trains the
algorithm so if if there's one term that
got used again and again and again and
again on these clickbait T or
inappropriate or yeah baby is not
there's plenty of stuff that's clickbait
t des that is misleading purposely
misleading yeah or or like people trying
to spam or people trying to like game
the system because youtube doesn't like
people gaming the system and that's why
everyone who
not gaming the system is paying like
there's this one channel who I'm sorry
I'm kind of like jumping back a few
topics but like an interesting example
of how like this YouTube robot like /
just hurting some creators who are
really making a good go at things a lot
of channels try to like spam YouTube
with a whole bunch of content by using
Robo readers so what they do is they
like type up like a text or and then
they just put like bad pictures behind
it and they can batch out hundreds of
videos per hour perhaps from all these
content sites and upload them that all
these channels and they're flooding
YouTube with its low content click beta
type things for one reason or another
and so YouTube's shut all that down and
it says like any any Content that has
the robot voice as the majority of the
channel gets shut down
and you know one channel that was hurt
there's a History Channel that kind of
has an AI as a personality and they put
all this time research everything into
this content it's highly produced
multiple people there's animators and
their their main character is this
robotic voice oh my because it's like
it's an AI channel that's like reviewing
history or something but because they're
using the robot voice as the main voice
all of their videos are getting
demonetised because youtube thinks that
they're low effort videos so much time
into it that's crazy I mean I understand
like why they they were trying to crack
down on the other things and why they
might put that rule in place but it's
like there's unintended consequences you
know there's innocent bystanders - what
if we get flagged because of the
supervisors voice majority of the
content whereas goop where is goop yeah
we're just using such a high quality
voice synthesizer you do trust us okay
ready for some more caca crap peepee
poo-poo
all of them are monetized beryl do you
want attack
they're so fun I'm so curious to see if
this video gets deep monetize you know
we need to do we need to name this the
most friendly and happy title we can yes
like the most the most safe words can
look up the safest words and title this
video safe words they replace it with
we're happy and friend a happy friend
podcast okay speaking of that
demonetized de monetization and de
monetize all of them bad no oh what oh
wait let me guess which is a good one
all right don't do monetize demonetised
it's um yeah for the three yeah
demonetized past tense de monetization
and de monetize like present tense not
do monetization is okay yes yeah cuz
that's like a news thing that's like a
normal thing okay the other two what are
the other two demonetised and de
monetize the monetize is safer to
monetized is definitely bad yeah you got
it right demonetized is bad yeah de
monetization and de monetize our good
yeah cuz most people use demonetized as
in like my videos a big do monitor burn
Rance Rance Rance justified right yes
yeah you're talking about yeah um but
put in to monetize in your title
demonetized you again it's like a it's
like a harsh system and a harsh cycle
whoo okay cemetary abandoned cemetery is
bad abandoned the safe yeah alright
because they told me a good wedgie
pants wedgie is demonetised pants are
safe
they're both do you monetize parents
well what if water for making pants I
cause my pants like Sofia's video she's
like I work clear pants for a day clear
pants that's definitely demonetised
it is actually think she said clear
jeans summation okay Oh
why what if she uploaded it it gotta be
monetized and she changed the title to
clear jeans
to clear jeans maybe cuz I wonder like
they're not you can't really like pants
are generic enough that they can be made
out of any material because we always
like we watch that video yet of hers
we uh we heard a while ago that like
uploading your video like a few days in
advance
is good for the algorithm to like
inspect and then like either give you a
good yes or bad no it's a bad no then
you can try changing things and you can
try changing things who are peeling it
or whatever before the video goes out to
the public because you don't want to
launch a video get all those views and
get not paid for like the job that
you're working the bigger thing is when
you get you monetized then you just
don't get pushed
oh yeah that's about to shows your video
momentum yeah so so there's also another
reason why I want to stay ahead of our
schedule okay hit me
okay these are all individual words one
of them was not on the list but I had to
do them all together package thief
versus glitter bomb trap and I'm
referring to the mark Rober video title
where he did the glitter bomb wait all
of those words individually individually
packaged thief verse glitter bomb trap
what package thief
verse good bomb trap okay
glitter was not on the list all the
others were I'm like this this sounds
strange but I need to write them down
cuz I'm like look at them visually
package thief verse glitter bomb
okay higher predictions tell me I'm just
gonna guess each word and you're gonna
tell me if I'm right or wrong okay bomb
bad correct trap bad incorrect traps
good verse okay it's good yep thief okay
you're right package package package
package
oh just bomb just bomb just bomb yeah so
it's like with that so it's like where's
other words okay enough or like it
seemed more whitelisted because he's
such a prominent creator there is one
interesting phenomenon that we though we
went through and it was a painful period
of time but after our propane cannon
video every single one of our videos for
eight or ten videos got be monetized and
they're all just normal DIY video how to
make a gallery wall yeah yeah the
gallery wall got you I was very
indignant about that it's like we're
hanging pictures on a wall we're just
describing how to measure guys the word
hang that's violent how to hang but I
think that one one thing that worked in
our favor in a way is we kept on getting
demonetized we kept on sending it a
human reviewer who said oh no this is
okay actually I wonder if we got some
like points on our side saying like this
channel has been reviewed by human X
amount of time okay and always been okay
maybe we have like a certain acceptance
like if a channel has never been tested
YouTube doesn't know how trust where
they are but if since we've been tested
ten times maybe that like kind of
shields us a little bit from the future
we've never been demonetized on our main
channel since never since 10 in a row
YouTube's like let's stop wasting human
time it's been about a year it's been
two years Wow yeah almost two years
that's awesome okay
it's very epic very epic employ employed
employees employee employed employer
employers employment one is different
from the others I'm not gonna tell you
which way it goes okay but you don't
think that's all individually do them
slowly employ employed employees
employee employed employer employers
employment you just discuss when you're
never employed and isn't what is
employed bad no so they're all good
except for employees plural wait wait
wait what
I know employees is the bad ones is the
bad one I was thinking employed because
it was like people angry or like
something like that or like employees
employees I don't I have no reason for
this I have no guess weird right there's
so many other employee employee what's
the theory like I'm sure like oh my guys
I'm sure that there's conspiracy
theories abounding all around around all
sorts of different terms on this list
speaking of which conspiracy conspiracy
is contact sensitive no it's good okay
weird right that's like I heard you know
word was YouTube was cracking out on
conspiracies but like the word
conspiracy is okay yeah through other
ways maybe but maybe it's like it
depends on what the conspiracy is so I
still stand by like if it's moon landing
okay moon landing demonetized
nope oh good that's good yeah even
though that was like an example of like
moon landing conspiracy its but the work
you could have moon landing conspiracy
and that could be your title and you do
qualifies yeah what about what if it was
fake moon landing oh I don't know I
didn't look at the word fake we could
okay I'll keep going and well if you
guys are interested and you want to
brave this list cuz as Caitlin mentioned
there's scary words on there there's a
lot of words that I didn't even know I
can only assume that they're bad
there are scary words in there but we
will link the video where we got this
list the reason
those who were involved warner at the
city video cuz he has like everything or
do you want to just link everything
individually in ours let's do both okay
so so so please inner city to give him
the the video credit and everything
super fast just so that we're fully
citing her like what we're talking about
- I feel like it looks good due
diligence okay relaxing relaxation
safe safe relaxing is not safe
relax isn't weird right cuz think of all
the like relaxing music to do homework
teen relaxing explosive diarrhea
satisfying satisfying relax of diarrhea
conspiracy dozens of explosive diarrhea
does I combine all the worst words in
this list as you guys might realized by
now we have a child essentially the
sense of humor okay three numbers six
six six one three three seven
aka leet and 4:20 Oh what okay six six
six leet 4:20
do you want a hint no okay I got it
well I'm gonna give me one hand how many
are do you monetized one is do you
monetize one is the amount as that's
what I was gonna guess so it's pretty
much right already pretty much um 666
lead 420 420 yeah cuz that's the most
illegal by the law Oh
I mean lead isn't bad it's just it's
like you know certain subcultures and
stuff that none of the subculture is bad
necessarily but I think that I like the
420 I could see that because it deals
with the law and YouTube is like really
like don't sue us
yeah that's true okay munchies do you
monetize nope
really I know right 420 420 is monetized
and one cheese or not
wait no opposite please do you monetize
munchies are okay I know right very
inconsistent
they inconsistent yeah it's interesting
okay Oh Jay Simpson Shrek Jonas Brothers
[Music]
I need to fix that peeking Oh Jay
Simpson Shrek and what other Jonas
Brothers Jonas Brothers safe yes
Shrek demonetized did you say that only
because you've seen the memes no oh yeah
shrek is demonetized
it was like memes about what there was
one meme okay and then OJ Simpson do you
want iced nope
really yeah so I just saw Jonas Brothers
and there is like a wild card yeah weird
right
like maybe is it because they're all the
Shrek memes maybe it's cuz I construct
is a very popular person and memes maybe
yeah maybe that's it huh okay this is
interesting one Democrat Republican
what Democrats safe Republican
demonetised reverse what Democrats do
monetize we're hopeful can save gonna go
crazy with me no right is that crazy
I just didn't like you would think that
they'd have to treat them equally yeah
unless like I don't know I don't know
that's really weird that's weird
[Music]
human safe know all those like horrible
human shrek videos that are being made
combined here I'll do a couple more
sympathy anger sympathy bad anger safe
yeah because if you're including those
two is to give this opposite and there
has to be opposite losing so many
criteria for guessing these yeah and
sometimes it's because I know you
yeah and I know the game you're trying
to design think it's like crazy
um nosebleed do you monetized but it's
not what yeah what Oh cousin I thought
kids were willing Marvin he had a video
where he had a nosebleed
dream on has for showing blood or
something like that I know that's always
like oh it's safe so I guess like the
word is safe but if you show a nosebleed
it gets demonetized cuz that's happening
William sometimes sometimes okay um
here's three and I bring them up because
they're all words that we have used in
videos okay
knife knives and quake quake isn't like
the game on our gaming channel knife and
knives have both both been used on our
main channel one must be demonetized
knife is the more dangerous term knives
is safer and quake is safer you
kind of right knives is safe yeah knife
is not quake is not quake yeah I don't
know maybe it's contact sensitive here
is contact sensor is 49 monetize because
it must be cuz 70 fortnight videos every
time yeah I don't know well I think like
quick is also like a word yeah like if
someone does a cool resin project and
someone leaves in the comments Evan and
Caitlin are quaking you know or like
when we do holo and they're like
Christina's quaking or earthquake no
biggest quake ever yeah but yeah like so
we have knife and our Damascus knife
series but I guess cuz we had enough
other safe words it was okay it's
interesting who knows the the workings
of the black box not us yeah um here's
another interesting one Lindsey with an
A and Lindsey with an E what it must be
like there were also like full celebrity
names so when it was a celebrity name
yeah
it included the person's full name okay
that's so interesting okay so this I
have no clue I can't guess yeah Lindsey
with an a as bad Lindsey with an e is
good
I'm sorry forgive you Lindsey's with an
A you listening most of my favorites
that's so interesting I'm just gonna
read through these and see if any of
these other ones shock me I gotta hit
most of them yeah restaurant restaurants
monetize cuz it's like so many
restaurant and food related videos most
of these I was able to hit actually that
might have been oh here's a few that I
didn't add in my list yeah Naruto's okay
George bad
yeah bra is bad enjoyed as bad example
as bad extreme as bad gallons bad gallon
is backpack is bad pack is bad oh yeah I
meant what yeah like a life hack like if
you do a life hack doesn't need to be
life hack one word oh my gosh yeah it's
crazy test that's crazy and I see
there's also like memes and stuff in
here like and and controversial things
like Momo because I felt if I go talk
about Momo and he said all those videos
got demonic
mmm-hmm or like Joker a lot of there's a
lot of news about the Joker right now
yeah Joe congratulations Joker's do you
monetize Wow
yeah cause like there's a lot of there's
a lot of controversy going around on the
Joker and how its portraying mental
health and how its portraying so if you
put Joker mental health you're screwed
both those do you mind oh my god so
weird it is hard because you know people
a lot of people make content on YouTube
as their jobs and I understand that
YouTube is in a tough place because you
know if YouTube doesn't get control over
these videos that are upsetting
advertisers everybody loses because all
the advertisers are gonna pull out no
one's gonna get Adsense and then
everybody loses YouTube is gonna shut
down and then and then what we do like
what what is where's everyone gonna go
all these content creators all this
content will just poof go right without
YouTube I don't know weird would be nice
as if YouTube had like a selection like
a Council of youtubers that it could
talk to ya about these big decisions
like people that have been on the
platform a long time people of various
so the compromise that we come to
because it's like we need to do
something to appease these advertisers
we were thinking this this and this and
youtubers can say like hey what about
this you know that'll make everyone
happy or at least everyone less unhappy
or even with the whole thing with like
the checkmark like if they just had some
youtubers run that past they would have
saved a lot of hassle and sadness
yeah you know but I feel like and of
course the more people you have in the
room when you're trying to make a
decision the longer decision takes make
and time is money and you know I
understand there's not a perfect
solution like also rolling out a
strategy and then rolling it back that's
a lot of wasted money too you know and
like I still I feel bad for YouTube
because I feel bad for YouTube and I
appreciate them I appreciate YouTube so
much yeah YouTube lets us do what we're
doing but it's just interesting to try
to think of like the different ways that
could be better cuz there are definitely
problems and like I wanted to get better
yeah all right I think I think that it
will good faith in you too it kind of
has to yeah it has to also don't think
that YouTube's gonna sit still because
they have been changing things well
here's the thing
so like if you ask public opinion about
YouTube I feel like there's more
negatives now than there were a few
years ago yeah I feel like overall
negative or opinion public opinion of
YouTube is more negative now and if that
in the same way that that that
advertisers don't want to be associated
with content that is observed as being
negative if the if the public opinion
YouTube because Nick becomes negative
enough they may not want to associate
with YouTube so it's in YouTube's best
interest for themselves and the
advertisers to improve the public
perception of themselves yeah so it does
kind of have to happen yeah yeah it's
interesting
well that's a hopeful and hopefully
hopeful message we're running long and
you know what next podcast let's try to
avoid in YouTube talk let's take a
youtube break for a little bit but for
now it's the time for thing of the week
my thing in the week is what we're about
to watch right now
yes it's 10:30 at night yes we have
other things to do but you know what
Shane just released his new video in his
like the beautiful life of beautiful
world of Jeffrey star series and that
series is just fascinating it's so good
there's there's so many interesting
things about it even if you're like I I
don't know don't really know who Shane
Dawson is I don't really know who
Jeffrey star is I'm more interested in
the beauty community watch it it's just
so fascinating to see this whole world
like it's a side of YouTube that we're
so far away from or so so far but it's
still it's a very unique piece of
content I have to say it's not like it's
not a movie it's not a TV show it's not
like a normal YouTube video of a
documentary but in like a youtube style
but in the YouTube style and it's like
so like you like raw and so like it's so
well cut together the story is really
well crafted but at the same time it's
like you can tell that they're just
filming pretty much the whole time I
can't they must have had so much content
but they tied it all together to make it
a good narrative and I think it's just
it's just a very interesting I mean like
the sounds really weird to say but like
Shane Dawson is like doing YouTube on
another level yeah and I think that like
there are YouTube classes out there and
I'm sure that's Shane Dawson's evolution
and his content and his switch to the
style could be like something that
people look at and study in these
classes which is a weird thing to think
about
yeah oh you mean like when you said
YouTube class is like like college
college class on YouTube Shane Dawson's
evolution as a case study
yeah and analyze what it is that's
creating this phenomenon yeah it's it's
just super interesting if you watched
his other like YouTube documentaries and
you like those you'll like this too I
think I mean we've only watched episode
1 we're about to watch episode 2 so one
was good at least but we're excited
about - yeah Kailyn what's your thing of
the week I think it's something that
sadly just finally died after
like five or six years but I want to get
another one immediately it's a touch
faucet in our kitchen it was like like
one of the first and few like treat
yo'self things we did in the beginning
when we first bought our house we
they're they're more expensive yeah
they're mark cents if we needed a new
faucet and I think we had like a Lowe's
10% off fun they obviously went
sponsoring us at the time and we were
like let's treat ourselves let's get it
touch faucet cuz then you just touch it
and it turns on and off and we're so
used to it we're so spoiled if we go
literally anywhere else handle and so
ours has just been amazing and it just
recently it's also about five years it
didn't fully die like I think we should
plug the thing back in because it still
works most the time we are I think it's
uh it's either a issue with a sensor
basically it's a capacitive touch sensor
and one thing that could have happened
is like you know there could be build up
along the stem and like it's not like
it's always connected or it's never
connecting or whatever but there could
be electrical problem or it could be the
solenoid this isn't firing anymore you
know cuts like it's a normal faucet it's
just all it is it's just a valve a valve
that opens and closes and and that is a
very simple thing but when there's like
you know conductivity and when there's
solenoids and you know like seals and
stuff because it's it's not just a
simple valve there's a lot of components
so you're upgrading complexity it's so I
think good so we're about to get another
one yes like if we can't fix this one
we're gonna get another one so the one
that we bought and they they're still
making it there's like a new version of
it nice the brand is Delta and there's a
few 200 cents I remember that but
there's a difference a few different
styles we have Ashton one so if you just
search like dolt we'll put a link to it
yeah Delta Ashton oh you know Amazon
yeah yeah yeah so like you know willing
both you can get locally or online
whatever works
for you guys find the best price doing a
research it's like I mean it's a little
it's like it's more expensive now than
it was before it's like 300 I think we
got it for them too but like it's so
when you when your hands like if you're
a cooking chicken you just can tap with
your elbow and then there you go yeah
it's so nice I don't want to touch the
faucet with my chicken faint hands but
even like chicken fingers like we have
hard water we don't have like a water
softener in our house and so I don't
like touching things with wet hands cuz
I'm like it's gonna leave hard water
marks so like after I wash my hands I
get well a normal person would like
touch with their elbows I touch it with
my nose but like there's it comes in
handy all the time
and I find like it's easier to you know
turn the water off when you don't need
it you I don't leave it running as much
unnecessarily because it's so quick and
easy to just tap it rather than like
fully turn it off and on again and we
just have it set at the perfect heat
level and we just never adjust it yeah
we pretty much fully yeah hey guys well
thank you so much for spending some of
your time hanging out with us we really
appreciate that you guys prioritize us
to make us part of your day and you know
if you guys have any subjects that you
might want us to cover in the future
topic we have the community tab and if
you just navigate over to our YouTube
comm slash evident km podcast hit that
community tab we have a thread there
where you guys can suggest topics elbow
topics that you think might be
interesting and you know just get
involved and you know if we do answer
one of your questions maybe you can
share it with a friend
or just share the friend anyways because
we love you